i think
it's just been a very interesting time
right i think uh so much has happened in
these two years
technology zooms
george floyd
i mean it's a lot right
me as a creative all of those things of
influence and touched me and i think
it's just great that we can start to see
people again i could do this with you in
this conversation you're going to hear
about dressing oscar winners the return
of the catwalk and whether working from
home killed the suit
[Music]
if you've been dressing for work from
just the waist up
you've definitely missed this
the crowds
a touch of glamour
dressing up and heading out
he has dressed heads of state royalty
and hollywood stars on and off screen he
describes a suit as a coat of armor and
believes wearing one boosts confidence
he is a tailor after all
now he's back for london fashion week
hello and welcome my guest today is the
fashion designer and savile row
powerhouse oswald bowtank oswald great
to have you thank you thank you i have
to say the best dressed man i think i've
had in the studio thank you i'm going to
take that
i'm definitely going to absorb that yeah
absolutely you should you have not let
us down it's beautiful what is this this
is so this is uh this is actually a
flannel
very english fabric but the design is
based on
a fabric called the kente cloth which is
a fabric that is born out of ghana
and specifically by the tribe of shanti
who
you have specifically young men who
weave it hand weave it men what do you
think yeah men exactly
there's a whole superstition about women
weaving and okay there's always a
superstition
exactly so and the fabric is always made
for effectively chiefs which are
effectively kinks
so the way it's like a the kenticos like
a coat of art um
your um your tribe exactly
so um so i decided to take that
and
mix that with
english tradition flannel
take the and usually it's multi-colored
so i take the i took all the colors out
and made it one solid color i used
fashion and color as a way to modernize
the traditional suit and over time
you know i never recognized that my
culture
my cultural roots were influencing my
choices in color
so my color palette was very african
about realizing was african because it
just
the color made sense to me yeah you know
i always went for
color that had a richness and depth
because if you have a richness in depth
and the color it means
you know you more people can wear it
everyone say i you know i'd hear many
times that
i can't wear that color because it
doesn't work and i say well actually
it's that's really all it is actually
it's like what shade
there's like a thousand different
versions of blue and
it's endless
so it's all about the right shade so i
developed my own sort of color palette
of shades that meant many people could
wear and then it evolved from there and
then at a point
when i recognized that my color palette
was very based in
my african heritage that's when i
started bringing more
of my uh my understanding in terms of
tech style into my work
london fashion week it's back there's
been a break of course the pandemic and
this is your first time showing in 12
years can you imagine a while
so are we seeing things like this in the
collection uh you'll see definitely
hints of this definitely i mean this is
sort of like become my sort of like my
house design fabrics so you'll
definitely see that and the
other variations of it so so the show
can you i know you can't tell me about
the designs but is there a theme what's
the thought behind it
so i did this huge show in new york in
uh 2019
and it was the show was actually was
called ai
interesting enough
but instead of saying artificial
intelligence it was uh
all about
the individual so i flipped the letters
and i called it authentic identity so it
was more
using the language like this and so the
show itself was this bridge between
african-american culture and africa
and finding a way of bridging those
those those positions
and so the collection really was a real
clarity on that so my show that i'm
doing
uh
here in in london is
i'd say an expansion of that
now we're kind of in the the sort of
like i said the sort of post
george floyd uh
you know time
i thought it'd be great to sort of
celebrate black culture in this country
over the last 50 years
it's interesting there's a a company out
of nigeria fun enough
a fintech business which is homegrown
out of nigeria
but um it's a platform that uh
enables uh farmers they have like nine
million farmers on the on on their
platform
helping them with the agriculture
business and they've actually
came in and
effectively supported and sponsored this
event that i'm creating
and for me that's quite special because
historically
you know i would never thought
that an african tech business
homegrown could
be in that position to do that they're
about to list
on the new york stock exchange so the
whole thing you know behind the scenes
through to the designs
is is funded and the design has that
link yes i think but more importantly
it's it's it's a very important point
you know because
in the the in this shifting change of
time it's about
having a voice right
and you know a voice is a designer
you know voice in the tech world there's
all this there's this big debate about
do you have enough women do you have
enough you know representation or you
brought black representation
all of this
has been a very loud
you know shout for the last let's say 12
months right
and what's a beautiful
and i feel
quite like happy about
is that uh
the traditional rule of it is
i would have to go elsewhere to get
the support right and it's great that
it's coming from from africa
to actually
support something here that's really
important because it's very easy to
lose track
of one the influence
and the creative influence of the
culture here
because
what makes actually london special i can
say london because i'm a londoner
is it's a malting pot of lots of
cultures
and
sort of
being able to
respect and receive that i think is is
london's future
and so i feel that this show will be a
very good
example a countless for that realization
because it's not about
hitting you over the head with
this is you know who i am i'm
you know i'm black and i'm proud it's
not about that it's more about
this is who i am
and it's great
and i'm great i'm happy to be here and
contribute
yeah so that's really what the show is
about i want to get into some of your
designs and how you come to those but i
think what's fascinating with the
pandemic is
fashion will have changed i mean it's
always changing but perhaps this is one
of those moments where we don't go back
potentially especially men to suits uh
we were already moving away from them
but now if you've just been on a zoom
call look look i think
it's just been a very interesting time
right i think uh so much has happened in
these two years
technology zooms
george floyd
i mean it's a lot right for me as a
creative all of those things of of
influence and and touched me and i think
it's just great that we can start to see
people again i can do this with you
right and so um
in terms of what i'm going to do with
the collection um
there's a strong cultural african
cultural aspect that
is probably more
visible in my collection my work now
than it has been previously
and
and a real celebration of that
not that i never did it before but i
feel
the time
where we're in today allows and more
importantly i think it's important to
demonstrate
i still have
the traditional values of my savoro
background because i
i love that i love the tailoring of that
and so you see that very distinctly in
the collection
but also there's an embrace of this
casual wear because no one's had to wear
a suit for two years i i think it's
quite sad that we've seen the decline of
the suit already and now perhaps it's
it's maybe gone even more we've seen in
suit sales and all of that it's down
it's really down yeah i mean covert
definitely
uh kind of compounded that and i think
prior to that there was this birth of
sort of like
casual wear in a way that is it was
moving into our
even our work lives in a significant way
but i
where i why i position myself you know
tailoring was never a uniform in my
world
you know tailing was a choice so
you know people would come to me for
special occasions
you know weddings uh
award ceremonies
and so the the
the dynamic around how i work is more
about pleasing the finding the
the ingredient for the wearer for
whatever the occasion that you
you need to suit for so it's slightly
different it is but i suppose i'm just
asking maybe as well for your view on
whether you know that moment i don't
know the exact moment but people stop
wearing hats you know when we i wonder
if you think the pandemic is one of
those moments not necessarily just with
the suit but kind of
where we get even less formal in some
ways yeah yeah
no i think for sure
the pandemics made us or
not make maybe paid
the same amount of attention because
you're at home right
you're doing zoom calls and
but in the same breath now it's starting
to shift
we all want to go out and now we're
starting to think about what we're
wearing
so that's changed what's interesting is
is the purchase on on the online on
e-com because apparently there was a lot
of purchases but very particular type of
purchases online and elasticated
bigger trousers exactly exactly so you
know that's quite interesting and
and there's no question that ecom
universe as of course as a
consequence of the pandemic has really
shaped
the business and for sure i've had to
react to that i think that's interesting
as well because during lockdown did you
have to do consultations remotely and
how did you find moving the business in
in that way and trying to make those
connections can you do it it's it was it
was very unusual actually and uh you
know i tried a few consultations on
on zoom which i did personally and that
was quite interesting i ended up
cracking a lot more jokes i was more
funny on zoom
because the whole thing seemed so crazy
to me because you're like trying to work
out but could you step further back
to from the screen yes and you know
you're talking to see you you're talking
about ceos running like 120 billion
dollars you know could just move could
you turn around
i think there is a way to do it
um i need to sort i need more time to
figure it out well and the advances in
technology the idea that you don't need
to measure in person by hand it can be
done by machines what do you make of all
of that i think we're still i think it's
the text out there i just
um
i haven't personally been able to
experience it i mean the
ultimately the best way we do it is if
there's some way you're able to use that
facial recognition tech
on the body i'm actually of the view
that the future would be
that everything is made to measure
really and somehow
there is uh
a manufacturing unit that in a way that
you're at home and then
you have a request
of something and it's made for the
factory and then sends you
and i
i feel
that it's possible in the future for
that to happen
because it's kind of mad that it
couldn't right that all of it is such an
estimate the idea that one size of of a
type of size could fit so many people
exactly but it's not it's not just that
because
the nature of the business is that i
don't know who's going to purchase it
so if i don't know i have to make
20 variables of size to fit you
see and so what happens is
it's designed to create waste
so
if you know the measures
then you don't have to make the five
sizes so that can find you the route to
a greener future but i mean big fashion
fashion because the hugest houses of
this and i'm not talking the couture end
i'm talking the faster and they still
just don't work on anyway that level do
that the amount of waste is huge
this is a massive issue no no absolutely
and but the thing is it's it's also a
challenge for them so
unless you're controlling your
manufacturing
which a lot of them
don't you know they may have really good
agreements with manufacturers it's a
very difficult one to
to change outside of
creating a system where you can bring
the garment that you're no longer
working back
where it could be recycled
i don't see how they're gonna resolve
that issue
how many suits do you have
good question i recycle so interesting
enough uh i only have as much as i need
in a given time so maybe it's maybe
20 yeah i worry i'll you know and i'll
you know
sell it on and i ask that because i'm
trying to think about
what you said about confidence and what
a suit can do yes absolutely absolutely
do you really feel in yourself when you
put on your suit
what do you feel how does it change you
well for me it's interesting because
i've been wearing suits since i was like
you know 16.
so i have a wholly different light it's
like pokemon
it's almost like putting in a tracksuit
i would imagine yeah right so i'm not
i'm not thinking about it
but if it's something
i think there's two things one is the
suits
and having a suit made for you
and then my intention
when i create a suit for an individual
so my intention is always to
uh
uh
encourage the wearer to be who they are
they're being their truth effectively
and so and i like to support that in the
way i cut the suit
and so once they look at themselves and
they feeling better about who they are
they show more of who they are suits and
clothes
are our armor a lot of the time they say
how we feel about ourselves a lot i
volunteer uh with the charity women's
charity called
smart works where we dress women who are
going for job interviews
and obviously not tailoring it's largely
donated clothes
but when you dress a woman when you
dress someone you help them get dressed
as an adult and not as a child
absolutely the feeling it gives them the
effort's gone into
their appearance is extraordinary yes
absolutely and and it's a very good
point you know
when um
you know i'm dressing uh
a client and he's putting the seat on
for the first time after we've done the
fitting process
you know the dressing of that individual
the experience of
putting the jacket put and helping me
put the trouser on is it's quite a
powerful
powerful relationship actually because
in fact they undress in front of you
yeah and then they dress in front of you
and then that experience when they look
at themselves in the mirror is is quite
something it's quite special are you on
social media i'm trying
my daughter says i'm hopeless
i'm really trying
you know i'm still on the fringes of
social media i think you should stay
there you know
i'm sorry i understand it's you know i
need to be more engaged
but it's it's interesting because i
think on one hand it's fantastic because
then you get a chance to re-express
and there's no in a way middle man to
your communication
but also in the same breath you know
anyone can say anything they want it's
truth or not they can just say well this
is an issue there's no gatekeepers in
quite the same exactly if you start a
business now certainly in the fashion
world you can just get people to wear
your stuff influences and then it grows
yeah
and which is i have to say i'm really
getting to understand because i think
the main thing for me is
is uh
the real kind of it's always about
connecting with the wearer and i always
go back to i'm very spiritual about my
work
and so you know
i like
that dynamic within
every purchase even if they're not even
aware that that's what's happening
you know once they put it on and they
start feeling good about themselves
because
you know i've now been long enough to be
able to say it you know because probably
historically i wouldn't actually
communicate in that way i'd say oh you
know they enjoy wearing my clothes but
it's been a long enough time
i know that's what it does right
and so uh
that for me is the most important thing
you know and
how you communicate that on social media
is is interesting
and the fashion world sometimes doesn't
have the best reputation divas and the
likes oh yes yes and the best behaviors
well i have to say though i have to say
in the old days of fashion you know um
you had a lot of that actually
um a lot of egos huge amount of egos
but
i'd say probably in the last
five eight years it's really changed a
lot i remember going to
fashion boards and
recent recent and everyone going upstage
and the speeches were
a lot more
considered
not so much about
what they've achieved or who they are or
who are they sitting with there seems to
be a big shift and it was needed because
uh how bad was it before yeah
at some point it was a bit just
ridiculous you know
there is a there's a theatre
and requirement within fashion because
you're creative you're an artist so
you're entitled to
you know
want to have you know purple roses or
whatever it is because this is the
vision that inspires you to create
but sometimes the performances went so
beyond the realms of reality that what's
your favorite they need they need to
they need to degrade something come back
they need to be out let's step back
what's your most um
divash request do you think
that's quite funny actually god what
have you always got to have well no no
actually me i'm i actually i think i'm
quite i'm very clear about what i want
i'm very detailed orientated when it
comes to my creative okay but uh
probably my only
major
diva moment i would say
actually is when i was a creative
director at yvonne she
i was uh
in the office design room
[Music]
and i wasn't getting things done the in
the time that i wanted and i couldn't
understand you know it's
like
a very diplomatic and
so i went for lunch with a friend of
mine and then i was saying that you know
guys
it's not stop moving quick enough and he
said yeah but they're french you know
you've got to you've got to throw a
tantrum
i said what you mean
got fried tantrum he said yeah you've
got to go now you've got to turn what
you want so i go and
i threw a tantrum and i got the stuff
done immediately what does that look
like you throwing a tantrum well it was
it was quite funny because it was
slightly performance i wanted i wanted
black tulips
it was a whole thing uh black tulips i
went black tulips everywhere for the
stage so it's the whole thing i want my
black sheets and i want them now
basically who's the best person you've
dressed are you allowed to say
or a memorable moment for you with all
these stories and all these people i
mean there's so many i mean it's the
story of daniel day lewis dressing him
for
the baftas when he won four gangs in
gangs of new york i think yeah
and uh he came to see me first and i
dressed him up and
that was really beautiful because he
gets he went on stage and when he won
the ward he's he talked about his tailor
but he didn't know how to say it because
it was uh because the thing is is when
you have that special moment there's a
lot of sort of pressure right and so
you
you um
well at least it's what i do i like to
make that moment when i come to dress
you a moment whether you don't feel that
so it takes a lot of that away and then
uh
when i dressed uh
jamie foxx when he won his oscar
for ray so that was uh that was great
incredible movie yeah great movie and
you know i've become very good friends
with uh jamie
and so that was special
i would say there's been many special
moments and is it special
of course they win and then you see them
and they look sharp they look how you've
talked about but is it the actual
connection that's made yeah that's for
me what's more important
is how they feel
you know many are
probably i'd say most of the time that
i've dressed people
the usual rule is you know to go down a
carpet and you you'd say look make sure
you
tell them that i dressed you all yeah
and i've always been kind of the
opposite to that i've always said look
if they said oh i mentioned i said look
don't worry about that
if you're feeling good it'll be good
thank you so much
and thank you so much for being with us
until we meet again do stay safe and
goodbye
tyson fiora his uh his view he says for
the best place for women is being on
their backs or in the kitchen it's
definitely not something we support
[Music]